Let's talk about fashion and beauty
as it pertains to political and social signaling.
So we've been deep diving about the beauty standard on my page,
and I wanted to take it a step further,
or at least pivot to a different subject.
All together, but within the same wheelhouse.
And that's how you present yourself
and how that signals to other people
you're positioning within the social stratosphere
and the class system. Now,
I've made it no secret on my page
that I grew up in a very wealthy area
in the suburbs of New York City.
Okay. There was definitely a archetype for dressing,
presenting yourself as I was growing up,
and I still live in a very wealthy or affluent suburban area.
And there is a uniform for the women around here and the men.
But we're gonna dive into women because that's where I land.
The thing about appearance as a social signal is
the entire reason people do this
is to signify to each other who they are willing to associate with.
But these are subtle things the further in you get,
and an outsider would not know.
I did a whole video recently about the whole golden goose phenomenon,
and it's expensive yet dirty looking for that reason.
It's supposed to give this illusion of authenticity
for people who don't know.
And the people who do know,
know you spent $700 on your sneakers,
that you're in the club. Or at least part of an Affluent,
upper class. Now,
I have never particularly felt comfortable
or fit in with the people that I am surrounded with,
which is why when I. Not just the only reason,
but one of the reasons why I went on a personal style journey.
Because the signals that were being sent to me growing up
and still today in my adulthood
are not ones that I can copy and mimic effectively.
It feels inauthentic to me.
And I don't know if it's because I'm in the south
or because I'm in a conservative area,
but blonde hair goes very,
very much hand in hand with this.
But not any blonde hair.
We're talking about effortlessly done blonde hair.
Blonde hair that looks like you just rolled off a beach.
Blonde hair that is perfectly undone,
yet slightly curly. That costs so much money.
Someone would think that they have undone hair.
They don't. It is very expensive to get your hair to look like that.
But only somebody in the know would know that.
And that no makeup. Makeup look costs a lot of money.
Those products are expensive.
And the skincare you have to do
in order to attain a perfect complexion,
without makeup or without makeup,
is also very expensive, as is the facials,
the Botox, the fillers,
the lasers, the peels.
There is a signifier of wealth and privilege
that comes with the beauty standard.
And again, I'm not taking myself out of that.
I don't think
There's anyone alive who can take themselves fully out of,
like, knowing their place within the beauty standard
or within the class system in this country.
But social class is another subculture
or sub genre of people
with an appearance and a beauty standard
that either admits people into the ranks or excludes them out of it.
And this is why people are so fascinated with Anna Delvey
and that entire situation.
Because how did she gain access?
How did she know the rules of the game without actually belonging?
That's why people are making her famous, because it's real hard.